[Music]
you know right cool hi thanks for coming
so what's that right so can we do retake
this mic is really loud no no better
yeah okay so yeah Jess adventures in
edulearn what what is it about right
so really it's less formal than my
colleague says my colleagues talk so
it's really about things that I'm doing
and some of the less normal things right
right it's a little bit different a
little bit but I'll let you be the judge
of it okay so our stats so a couple of
info about myself I am a cloud solution
architect for Microsoft so my day job
consists of working on with partners
Microsoft partners on blockchain app
development and general as your stuff I
could so I maintain a graphic
manipulation library in PHP called G
magic I've been doing that for 11 years
now yeah so let's please fever this is a
JavaScript conference but yeah anyway I
also do some personal finance moving
around Ledger's your life ahead of it so
I do like a electron I mean I keep
around like just CLI so that's for fun
and I also started a automation package
for kind of like it's kind of like a
cron for JavaScript so I presented that
about in gs con 16 yeah so that's kind
of like my open source
kind of like and that was so I also
created a book based on Bertrand
Russell's conquest of happiness so it's
really just sticking that book and
infusing some pictorial illustration of
what Bertrand Russell was trying to
explain so yeah let's dive in Jes in
Nashville and so we're gonna start with
the entrance the teapot right how this
how does user actually get into your app
right so most apps today you need to
login right or you need to be
authenticated somehow so so yeah the
first topic is about as Active Directory
and and how to work with it right so
that's there's life is like ad al-adel
Active Directory authentication library
and so I'm not using that this is a
different way and again like I say this
is like an adventure right so you can
have a look and see if this is suitable
for your projects so there is a very
specific subtlety that require a
different way in a while so why Active
Directory right
I presume some of you may already know
it's easier to is easier than managing
your own user base and identity system
it's scalable obviously is on the cloud
so you know it's not it's not
constrained to a server and it's also
very well integrated with enterprise as
and such okay so the traditional for
Active Directory looks like this right
the user comes from a browser it goes to
it gets redirected to authorize endpoint
that endpoint returns an ID token which
is then passed to a web server the web
server then does more talk more of
actually getting the the token another
token from an API that you can actually
use to communicate
I should make API calls the backend
server right but I wanted to show
something different
looking at that yeah that's totally fine
so what I'm showing here is basically a
react based active directory what does
that even mean right I need a I need a a
a framework
I need a platform that I can get on
right
I found Jason Moss dwt off example I
have met this guy but I found this on
github right and I think it's Australian
but anyway so he did a really good
example of logging in from a react app
so as you see from the left side this
react Redux GWT authentication example
so perfect for me so yeah is very
prevalent these days like we get a lot
more yeah even for intranet applications
so so I actually found myself in this
situation but I need a publicly
demonstrate ball platform so I'm using
this so what you see on the left is
react react without the WT
authentication and what you see on the
right is a GWT authentication so how
what happens is the front-end actually
serves the form for the user to login so
the user inputs the username and
password as you know you should practice
and that username and password gets
passed gets posted the backend the
backend authenticates the user and
returns the GWT token so very vanilla
things right so my my challenge right
why I'm doing this why why this
adventure is because of a specific
requirement
so the developers for example in this
case this particular react I was
thinking you know if I could find a way
to not modify the existing way that the
application does authentication you know
getting a user into the private parts of
the application and I wanted to keep
that process while wrapping around Azure
ad so that users assisting users that
are logging in if using a password can
do so and people can have the additional
option of logging in via Active
Directory so the crucial part here is
it's not like passport or anything this
is a custom based user name and password
authentication so again this is this is
not Passport if you do if you use
passport you can just use my small right
but if you find yourself in this
situation okay I already have username
password and I need to kind of like wrap
as we ad around yeah this may be
interesting to you and even more
interesting is what I'm using to do this
right I'm using this thing called a
state for me right so state is a
parameter that as your ad actually
accepts maintain shared knowledge
between the browser and the ad itself
and anywhere else that the user gets
redirected to in this case the it gets
redirected to the back end and you may
not necessarily want to redirect the
user to the back end you can redirect
the user like some other web servers so
if you think about as a ad Ryan if you
think that it is you know something
constraining it's not actually it's just
it's just a an endpoint there and you
can actually redirect any way you want
and and things with it and this is one
example of how that is done right so
moving on if you want to check out my
quote it's actually over on my github
yeah
and let's get started so before I make
any more right here's how the app looks
like you log in and then yeah you know
your login simples right so this is the
thing right without the modification
right and because VI is component based
I actually added like wrapper components
to make it easy right so the existing
code remains minimally modified right
there are some parts I added a link here
and there so those fast I cannot be read
because I need to show the link on the
front page but I can show you how we've
components actually can wrap things
around and and you know this I can
actually achieve the you know the
outside that I was showing this now so
yeah
the icing action is very simple you know
the user logs in the the action actually
eventually results in a post the backend
with the username and password in the
body right so in the body I mean when
it's posted through the backend what the
backend does is this is just an example
right there's an everyday and what what
the backend does is it uses the username
and password that's posted from the user
it actually use that to fine from the
array and if you find something great a
token and return the user object and the
token along the user object simples
great so what I want to achieve is after
after wrapping around right when the
user wants to login
it has the option to yeah go to
Microsoft login ID login and if he's
already sign-in you know we just go to
the app obviously so so that's what I
want to achieve though yeah so okay
let's get on to how I want to achieve
this right so here's the first part of
my mod the first thing is we act as an
active directory right obviously you
need we have the tenant ID and the
application ID specified okay so I'm
actually just putting this in a constant
over here and also we need the redirect
URL so here I'm using
you can actually place any redirect URL
but if it's external it has to be I mean
if it's not kind of local it has to be a
secure HTTP endpoint right so you can
actually redirect this anyway
and Here I am actually redirecting to
local so moving on when I get those
things the tenant ID application ID and
the redirect URI so you get this when
you actually create a and an app
instance in asthma ad right so here I'm
here in registration you can actually
see application ID tenant ID and the
redirect URI over in the azure portal so
getting this I place it in the constants
in my react M just now so all of that
right actually it's just a sample
redirect all I'm doing here is I'm just
creating a helper construct the redirect
well as the ad okay so then I add a
route to my app so this is f dot d s X
right so this is my main react app
component right so I just add a route
nothing very fancy here but there are if
you notice on line 25 the route actually
redirects the off URL that I created
with the helper just now right so what
this means is if the user hits a browser
and you know it
she does slash off she will get
redirected to the asthma ad login so the
private routes right so parts of the
application that are private you
actually go to this but to a specific
component so what this component does is
it actually gets a user object from
local storage meaning your browser the
local storage on your browser so if you
notice earlier right the decent most
example right login user has a user
object return the browser and and he
actually stores this right so the
presence of a user object indicates that
the user is
in and it's authenticated right so if
the user is authenticated we will show
the component whatever the user is
requesting and if it's not then you know
we redirect to the login page
okay and at the login page here as I
mentioned I can modify and wrap around
but this is one part I couldn't wrap
around because this is just a link I
need and authenticated and off link the
user obviously I can not do this as well
I can you know redirect straight away as
well it's uh it's really up to me right
well here I want to just add a link at
the bottom of the login page so that
here you know login with AD right that's
an option so yeah now let's talk about
the state parameter that I was using
right so as I mentioned I was using
States to do this and and and and it's
really a wrap around we don't really
modifying the the application right but
this state is really where the magic
happens okay if you read part of this
this paragraph here the state can be a
string of any content that you know that
you wish right so you know I wish for
the content to be a some kind of a
unique ID basically it's like a hash
string right so it's a unique ID that is
generated at the browser and you see
what happens to it right so that's the
state part the state again just as a
reminder gets carried around the
authentication of here right yeah so I
said as I mentioned the state gets
passed to the IAD as a parameter and as
rady then once authenticating the user
passes it on my back-end that I
specified as a redirect URI okay so the
back end upon receiving the state right
remember the state is actually stored in
a local browser in a browser in local
storage now the state has arrived at the
back end so I need to add a route to
receive the steal right so this is the
route that I will actually place in the
redirect URI
think that steep and this is just a
controller you know so the controller
actually sets the the state the token so
when I actually do this right the I the
active actually actually passes an ID
token my my back end over there right
and also along the states so what i'm
doing here is i'm using the state as the
key to local storage so i'm using local
storage on the server side it's a
simulated position see right but it's
pretty nifty so I really like this right
so I mean here is I know I just want to
store this somewhere with a key right
and the key is the state hash okay so
I'm storing the ID token now and I
redirect the user back to the front end
and upon receipt getting this on the
file
yeah so one thing more I'm Jason one
more example actually has this mop
back-end on the react itself this is
just for convenience you know if you
just want to run that rehab you don't
need to run the backend and you can
actually simulate that login but in this
case we actually do have a back-end so
so yeah but uncheck this this a note
okay so now we have a state on the front
end right so if this state I can
actually get my front end my react app
authenticate with my back-end
normally right I say normally but you
know normally meaning it gets a normal
that as I sing token that the app
already uses so what I mean by that is
practically I'm passing in the state
that I've start remember I've start a
state before I redirect they use it as a
ad right so now I have the state I
retrieved that user object and I'm
actually using that state hash login so
login with state and you have login with
state action here which is really just a
very standard reaction and here's where
the magic happens right the state gets
full force the post request and I'm
instead of username and password I'm
actually passing in
the state as the as the body of the
request okay and the end point I call is
different is now stay off which is you
know to authenticate we've state so
passing into the end point now to the
back end the back end then this the
state
remember I've start this earlier in the
back end right so the back end now uses
the state retrieve the the ID token
that's not with that hash okay so if
that ID token yes way where the user
objects get created so if that ID token
retrieve and I find that oh yeah this
user actually has an ID token it's not
like some unknown user is already an
authenticated user I use the ID token I
which I dig the ID token I obtained some
of the data from the token and use that
to construct the app's actual JWT token
and return the JWT token along with the
user object as per normal
so yeah now we get so I hope you see you
know how the existing kind of like all
of the app logging in with this token
creation is actually preserved okay yeah
so so that's that right the flow is done
a couple of security considerations if
you are you know if you're keen on using
this technique so one of it is here
remember that you know the user actually
claims his ID token real estate right so
one thing to know is when you actually
when the user actually seems that you
can remember to expire that token you
know destroy the token this is to
prevent the token from being caught from
being retrieved by any other users right
so this is just kind of like hygiene
right so other considerations are there
as well right you know jump over here so
there are other considerations so this
is the token expiry thing there are the
considerations okay so remember that we
were using
this endpoint right this specific
endpoint slash token so we don't want to
really allow force attack on on snack
token and slash state off so what you
want to do is some rate limiting there
and as API management actually has
mechanism that helps you do limiting or
even to block out any unwanted requests
from non relevant endpoints or you know
holes or notes in the flow so one of the
fool here is active directory actually
goes to the back end right so you want
to have any other people calling any
other not calling slash token for
example besides Active Directory service
so that's one thing that you can
restrict yeah I should I skipped a
couple of other stuff here but it's not
really remember earlier I was I was
saying that we need to actually lock the
user out right and here's how I'm seeing
a react component as a wrap so the
reason why most original original
example right uses the login component
logout right so what happens is in the
login login page constructor it calls a
dispatch dispatches a logout right but
which is cool you know but I needed the
the the logout action Ryan actually thus
[Music]
he actually does this it removes the
user object I need to do more right so
because I now have a state object so now
I've wrapped around a login page I
extend I mean I create a lot of pitch I
wrap around the login pitch okay as you
see the render is actually a login page
render and from there I do a state
logout so the state logout actually
removes that state so when the user
actually goes to the logout page it gets
a clean slate there's no more any entity
store
in local storage okay
so yeah that's the that's one part of
the adventure done right so around
Active Directory logging in and all that
a alternative way of dealing with it
yeah so this is quite wrong you are just
using react and there's some calls
there's no live reader you were using
and all that so if you're keen you know
you could check it out it's on github
right so the next thing I wanna go to is
storage okay and and there's also a kind
of a unique way of using story yes so I
wanted was I was not happy with you know
just looking at a portal I wanted to
actually get that data as a developer
you know I love my JSON right so I want
everything in Jason's so yeah so there
are many stories available in in in in
in Ezra so that's a geodatabase and it's
a trial right but my favorite story is
actually as with table storage okay and
I like it because of a couple of reasons
so first it's really convenient to use
it right that's not oh it's not table
story the tables are not really
structured right like there's no you do
need to define this I mean you don't
even define a table schema or like you
know pre-existing structure for the
table you can just dump any entity into
it anymore the table will adapt you know
why were you dumped into it which is
very convenient for me right the next
thing is it's really super affordable if
you think about it right this is the
this is one storage on the cloud right
there you can store things and you're
just trashed by like the megabyte line
you know like similar to blob storage
kind of a pricing like almost similar
and you don't need to like turn on a
computer it needs to be you know turned
on all the time so things are like you
know you just rush like a per
transaction right and you get a lot of
free transactions to start with in any
case so yeah so I've been running this
for some of my ass and I haven't been
paying anything actually
so I really like this so I'm gonna show
how I use as your table storage I use it
for all sorts of things right I use it
to keep track of all sorts of things
personally and network but I'm gonna
start get on with it right I'm gonna
tell you why how one story of how I'm
using it so so this is a page right so
it's not really relevant to my story but
I want to tell this if you go to this
page and if you click on download what
typically happens is you get redirected
to another page right and we did that
fish there's some JavaScript that gets
you to where you actually want to
download things right so I think people
do this because they actually want to
analytics on like people downloading
their stuff so I'm cool with that
I wanted something even deeper than this
right so what is my my my question is
what if you know I go to my portal and I
download this so it's not tracked right
and what if people goes to the endpoint
directly and download and it's not
tracked and what if this is like a
private thing you know like this it's
actually a private blog right and and
it's not tracking as well you know if
you go to a page right unless so I
wanted something that is even at a lower
layer and you know even though I create
then pitch base analytics so yeah so I
went to read you know the docs and I
realized that yeah you know as usual
actually provides observation actually
provides an API and they actually API
that people are actually calling when
they actually goes get a blog is
actually get blog right but when I try
to charge it so this is May 14 2019 not
that long ago so this is something
recent that I was doing right so I went
as a portal and I try to charge it and
yeah it's not there so yeah so I was
slightly disappointed
but you know I was uh I mean a little
bit of noise with my team and I don't
know like some magic happen and on 31st
of me
20:19 and i went back to the same chat
and you know the get blop api is
actually there so so this is me I mean
that one download and you know there's
one download there and I should get my
chat which is cool but I wanted
something more because as developer I
want my JSON I don't just want to cut
and you know with JSON I can do all
sorts of stuff with it and what if I
want to have like you know some of the
other metrics because now I know that
there's so many other metrics I can play
with so yeah
aside from that there's also some
constraints right
these metrics right is trust I can it's
only for up to 90 days this is because
the retention period is 93 days but you
know is extendable there's some ways
which I'm going to show but yeah if you
do nothing you know it's there for 93
days for platform metrics so the
resources they do some diagnostic locks
as well and the minimum for that is 30
days but you can configure that oh you
know for activities that you do
unanswered as long as well and that's 90
days so the other reasons as well like
you actually own the data right for
reasons of you know this is one thing
that is very close to my heart right you
know my by me or by you using as your
right it doesn't mean that as you own
everything right that data is in the
sufficient agreement itself you know the
customer actually owns that data alright
so I've won that data and I want to do I
want to know that I have the freedom to
do whatever I want with it right so
that's one thing and the other thing I
want to do is maybe I want to reconcile
my cost right if you know I get this
amount in my in my bill and the bill
says I got this you know fifty thousand
transactions yeah and I want to know
that you know the transactions are
tracked at what time and all right and
you know you may have reasons as well so
so let's look at how how I actually get
this data from that you know that's
actually looking like a chart now from
as you all right
so before we move on further into that
part of things I can explore doing this
as your storage right there is for some
services you can actually just use
diagnostic locks diagnostic settings
just tell the service you know tell Ezra
to route these locks to Azure storage
keep it there for archival purposes
right
unfortunately I can't find as a story
here so then I went I went to look for
the documentation and in the
documentation I cannot find any blob
storage diagnostic locks available okay
so I look at for metrics and I actually
found time for metrics and I actually
found transactions being part of
platform metrics so now I need to dig
out that platform metrics form as you
write and JavaScript to the rescue
okay so yeah so that's one eventually I
have as a developer so I use this
particular package call as a monitor so
the SDKs actually super comprehensive
you can actually have one for most of
the practicum almost all of the services
that's actually there and and all that
is is actually on the azure
documentation as a REST API as well so
these packages actually wraps around the
the REST API and use a convenient kind
of like package that you know developer
can use straight away so yeah I'm
monitor so these are a couple of objects
and classes that are useful to me in you
know in getting that thing out of Azure
portal right so yeah as all new
developers I go start myself in with NPM
pitch of the package that I want to use
okay and doing there I get to this page
and I see actually that ms-office
actually useful
but I don't really want to do
interactive login as you can see right
there are many ways to authenticate a
user so interactive login is a very
useful wave if you're just testing some
things on the on the time you know right
so what it does is when you do this
right and you run new wherever this is
index not yes but this snippet of this
sample code what happens is a lime pops
out there's a URL there and then there's
like something like a there right so you
click the URL put in a call on the
browser and magically or your new app
gets an authenticated signal from Azure
and you know you get to run your code
but I don't want to do this right
because I have to host my coat on some
cron job on the cloud somewhere so what
I want is uh yeah it's actually this
right so how do I figure out what can I
do right so this is another thing that I
really love which is we just view code
and it's particularly intelligence right
so I have MS rest off there for me and I
know that I can use that login well I
have no idea what method name is call
right so you know as you know the magic
of intellisense I type in login and
suddenly you know these things appear
and now I know that okay cool I can
actually log in with maybe service
principal you know that sounds like it
yeah so this principle you know research
me so I don't need to keep my I don't
need to be authenticated with a browser
so with that I'm actually just I up so
that's you know I can even actually go
further right if I finish type if I tap
that and then you know the documentation
is actually in the editor itself right
and you know this is really cool but
reading the documentation is also just
pointing me to service principle which I
know really but yeah thanks for you know
telling me any case in that sense but so
now now I know that I need the service
principle so so I'm gonna segue a little
bit too
as we CLI right so I'm gonna use the CLI
to get my service principle I can there
are many other ways but this is what I
do so log in as command line and the
next thing is I want to leave my
subscriptions so I just want to
emphasize how important it is this right
because for me I have many subscriptions
I mean not that many at one time but you
know I but there's a nice tree lying
around right so I want to make sure that
this service principle is created for
the right subscription because if I do
get the wrong service referred to the
right to the wrong resource then you
know my core is gonna have a right so
here
always always specify the subscription
ID when creating this so I'm here is I'm
just using the agency are I create a
service principle for the Auerbach
purposes okay so then I get my
credentials here
so with these credentials I can actually
go back to my code right and you don't
go along the way so the next thing that
I find from the sample code that is this
I mean I read the sample code right and
I don't need to actually read that far
so because the next one seems irrelevant
to me at least by resource so yeah it's
like you know is skill right so I'm not
actually interested in Auto skill I'm
interested in metrics so but I learned
from here that you know client this
monitor measurement client is is pretty
interesting and maybe very useful to me
so I need essentially that and again I
use intellisense to guide my rewrite so
you know I go to this list and I found
that there's matrix and matrix don't
actually has a method called list okay
that sounds interesting right client
metrics list right so yeah I can
actually
intellisense my way further but
sometimes this is another
we things right I I find out is it's
better to just actually look at the cool
why is let me pause for a minute really
because the code is available to you
this is an NPM package right the moment
I do this in Vemma just right you just
to do code I can just do does this for
me already I mean I can actually just
come on click on list and okay the
actual of the package itself get a
deeper understanding of what the the
package is doing and I mean looking at
the documentation is awesome right like
you know I don't know my code this way
but it looks really nice here you know
now I learned that oh I need resource
you alright so what is this resource all
right thinking about it obviously I want
to get a metric from drop storage
I go to my block storage I first I
actually went to view it's not there
then I click on properties oh yeah
that's this resource ID there that seems
like a use resource you alright so I use
that you know plunk it into the resource
URI and then going further I also need
to pass in some metrics these optional
params we think that this is like super
useful for me to write so you know
imagine my joy discovering this okay
this is possible so now I get four
metrics I get to specify the time spend
I want the metrics for I get to specify
the interval the time drain and you get
to specify the metrics that I'm
interested in in this case it's
transactions and I know there's a list
of other stuff so I get to kind of like
filter my query on right so yeah running
that I actually get to this right so if
you look at the options I'm passing in
this metric names
this is comma separator so if you want
something else you can just put a comma
there and have another metric the metric
the possible metrics you know you can
actually check on the the as website
that ISO documentation for for block
service right
and I'm actually here filtering for
get block I say API name equals get blob
so if this call what I get is this
return okay it is again like you know I
was excited when I saw this because this
is exactly what I want right image of my
chat there you know all the time spans
and it's super easy to use because okay
this is not a very good view of this
yeah so this is the JSON formatted and
formatted JSON of the the object that
you saw this now so yeah I can actually
just use that time series array and you
know slow that into my table wow you
know that's fast okay so let's take a
look at a couple of attributes here
sometimes man is one I need to know the
time span that is that is being written
of the time series as drink returned to
me right so yeah a little bit of
dissection here so I realize that this
is from 537 637 one hour and the green
the granularity is per minute right so I
get minute level granularity of that get
blob count okay so with that let's move
on I realized that you know looking at
this right that's you know a lot of
empty objects if you look at here right
some of these objects have a total and
some that's not right so I realized that
hey I don't really need those objects
that has no count right plus if I still
need those objects with count then you
know I get even more cost-efficiency
with my table storage so yeah so then I
start filtering it you know so I am just
using a very simple array filter here
you know pass again if the object has a
total then then I can't then I put it
into my real metrics right so real
metrics is the final of things right
real matrix has an array of time a real
object that has a time stamp and the
count of that meaning that the time stem
represents okay so
I feel has achieved what I wanted to do
here so the next step is where I should
put this into table starvation and here
I show how easy it is to actually use a
table storage as well so the first thing
to do obviously is to go to my portal
and create a table that for this I can
actually do this with the no API as well
but I'm not gonna use if you have
because simply this is just six away and
I'm doing this one time right well of
course you can use the API if it's
repeatable or if you want to do
something that you can deploy repeatably
but anyway the Patil is really
convenient it is there for you so the
flexibility is there so with that table
there I actually went on to this
discover or look for a what's the SDK
that I use right and I realized that
okay I can't use version 10 the latest
generation of the storage SDK really
because it doesn't really have table
support yet all right so then I moved
the next available one which is v2 okay
yeah that's fine
so that's the flexibility of JavaScript
right so from that v2 I discovered that
these three these three objects help
write tip the object obviously the table
service itself created from the from the
area and this engen object right the
engine actually helps with specifying
the right data types for the table okay
so here's where the meat is how do I
insert that object into as the table
service why do here is simply I run
through my magnetics array I use that
objects in the metric arrayed create a
new entity and this entity has proper
indicative I mean proper data type
indicator to table service right so my
total is integer and metric time is
actually a time so this is the this
ensures that
the table service understands my
intended datatype so next what I do is I
then insert anything into the Downloads
table and yeah I get that entity in
table storage and yeah that's how easy
it is to really use the SDK so the
message from today my you know what I'm
trying to bring across today is that
from a new perspective it's really
useful gives you something beyond the
portal and it's really easy there's a
comprehensive API for as you know as a
developer you can use and if you have
codified that it can be reused and the
API is wrapped by some NPM packages that
easily you know NPM install and friendly
storages out there such a stable service
that you can use to persist if you need
to persist and you probably need to
persist these days right you know
creating apps these days
so I hope you take away some of those
key messages and if you want to look
further there's some suggestions for me
you may want to take the example from
today and maybe post it on some civiles
compute which my colleague Darren Evans
is gonna show in the next presentation
you may want to sync your table storage
to local storage so anywhere else just
for the sake of liberty you know just to
exercise your liberty and you want to
check out like some of those other
extensions of es code and we play around
with dock chain which is another cool
thing that Microsoft is coming out with
a lot yeah so some references here thank
you for your time
Darren